wasps they're pretty annoying but what
would happen if all the wasps in the
world just disappeared if there are no
wasps it's not just the insect that
would be lost but a complex society with
some surprising similarities to our own
wasps are a key predator and protect
plant life crops and other creatures
from spiders millipedes flies
caterpillars aphids and much more
they're also a lot smarter than we give
them credit for some wasps can recognize
each other's faces and they can be
trained to detect explosives and illegal
drugs and wasps are crucial pollinators
too every species of fig relies on its
own species of pollinating fig wasp for
Fertilization in turn more than a
thousand tropical birds and mammals
depend on figs and therefore wasps to
survive so let's give the Wasps a break
stop and watch them and see just how
amazing these disliked and wildly
underappreciated insects actually are